[Music]
second hour rotc
hi everybody
didn't expect the shooting in the middle
of the show did you
no no i'm i'm sure this is a
yeah it's fantastic mood to start
everything off hey clint you picked a
good day to be on bud
dude i'm still trying to catch my breath
i had to take out as many people as i
could before i got on here yeah
fair enough man what's going on man
clint from liberty lockdown what's going
on man
i'm sorry i don't even know what
happened man there was a shooting what
happened
give me the background bro
fourteen children do it at
it's like oh mlm god that was a terrible
joke how could i do that no i don't care
it's so funny but yeah no i still left
uh yeah apparently yeah apparently i i
don't know like uh we just all they know
that it was a
hispanic guy and walked into a school
and
shot like 14 people 14 children and one
teacher killed elementary school dude
[ __ ]
are we going to give them a proper intro
it's not like [ __ ] harrison smith's
popping hey look it's it's clint from
liberty lockdown he does the show there
you go it's not good it's not like
[ __ ] it's not like sword nerd is in
here for the [ __ ] harrison sword nerd
who's yeah he's
basically just thinks he's the third
mike of the show at this point
uh i'm your your average uh you know
libertarian nut case um so
even when i see shootings about kids i
just asked myself why the kids weren't
armed well that's that's kind of my
everyone should get guns and
my philosophy is if you gave everyone a
gun right
okay yeah [ __ ] would get pretty wild for
about a little bit for about 90 days and
then guess what and then it would settle
down
and that's it that's fine
everybody that doesn't know how to
handle a gun they get they're gone after
a very limited amount of time and then
everybody else becomes very respectful
and responsible and i think it's just a
better world by the way your view is
amazing can i just say very nice [ __ ]
jealous interview god
is a nice setup well thank you guys i i
just moved to miami like eight months
ago so i'm uh uh it's it's a better it's
a better lifestyle than california
thanks to gavin newsom who did his best
to ruin my life oh well they look it but
miami though
yeah i know i was talking i was actually
i'm a tampa boy man i'm all about my
tampa we hung out at it you know
we hung out at universal he was up we
were talking about like you gotta move
central florida central florida is the
best
bro you're only an hour and a half from
each beast from the atlantic and from
the gulf like hey
this straight line to daytona beach
to [ __ ] disney world and universal
and then straight down to busch gardens
saint pete yeah tampa like [ __ ] it's
it's pretty nuts you don't have to deal
with the cubans the old i4 corridor baby
yeah no i i think i'm going to end up
there eventually either there new
hampshire like central florida or new
hampshire
is probably where i ought to be um but i
didn't know i didn't know any better you
know i was just like miami seems nice
i'll check it out it's still i'm sure a
step up from cali i mean you're still at
a cali which is
significantly already much better
bro i already have to keep 16 more of my
income so that's nice what part of cali
were you in again
san diego san diego
which is very pretty by the way one of
the very pretty expensive ones but it's
super expensive to live there now it's
insane
yeah dude i'm building six houses right
now they're starter homes they're like
approaching a million dollars per it's
so insane are you building them like you
know gerald ford does you're out there
like hammering like habitat for humanity
or whatever he does no no i'm i'm trying
to make as much money as humanly
possible you really are a libertarian
bro
are you building uh little pod houses
because i know that's the new hot trend
little pod homes
here's here's a little here's a little
closet for you to sleep in and it's only
eighteen hundred dollars a month okay i
have to ask at that question as a
libertarian how much have you cut
yourself because of the bitcoin market
right now
because i've cut myself a lot i just
want to be no it's a hedge against
inflation that's what they promised
that's what they told me i am hurting i
am hurt and hurting
well this is this is why um i think
there's a problem when you have people
that are like
they're just so they're so dead set on
the belief that inflation is inevitable
and that you will have no setbacks and i
i had been cautioning people i was like
if there's a liquidity crunch which is
what we're experiencing right now uh you
will see much lower entry points into
bitcoin just so you guys for those that
don't know me i have a uh i had a
mortgage company i i retired in my 30s
like i i'm kind of a financial guy so i
can speak to this i was telling people i
was like you're going to have a lower
entry point to bitcoin i said this back
when it was at like 35 almost over a
year ago before it ran to 70 and and
then when it ran to 70 everybody's like
dude look at you you don't know [ __ ]
anything and i'm like hey
it's not over yet and then now we're
back into the 20s so hey long enough
time horizon i'm right by the way you've
been in miami too long you did a great
cuban impression bro like literally do
like you don't know what you're talking
about bro like that's just crazy dude
oh it's crazy but like you could get in
lower if you just have a little bit of
patience it's a little patience bro bro
try to get ethereum too bro like that
[ __ ] is like popping bro oh that [ __ ] oh
etherium's crazy man the guest piece are
you [ __ ] kidding me anyway bro i
gotta go work at daylan mall bro i'm on
my way i'll see you later i remember
when crypto was popping a while back and
i was trying to sell [ __ ] and he
couldn't even really like there was like
you know swaps and stuff that you
couldn't even do because the gas prices
of ethereum were out ray was insane when
it shot all the way up it was like
i mean even if i make money on this
trade like the [ __ ] gas fees alone
but you know you know the good news is
though the stock market's also tanking
yeah at least that's also happening
but hey at least we're also going to war
with russia but you know what's really
cool also china also hey hey listen
that's right you're a money guy i wanna
i'm gonna give you a business
hypothetically here you go here comes
i'm gonna throw one at you i'm excited
so let's say you take over the country
right
and your first daughter of business is
to stop all local energy production in
this country then the second step in
your plan is to start buying all of your
energy and oil from russia and then step
three is to start assassinating russia's
generals what do you think do you think
that's a good business you're a money
guy i feel like i'd probably get 81
million votes
and and ann and
88 billion dollars most popular
president in history don't forget that
88 billion dollars most popular i'm
fairly convinced that joe biden is uh
either the antichrist or or just like uh
weakened at bernie bernie zing us into
complete collapse
well i i can assure you sir that joe
biden is not the antichrist because if
you read the book of revelation everyone
loves the ants that's a good point the
antichrist obama really is the closest
we got yeah
because everyone liked that dude
you know what i mean
that's true that's a good point yeah i
know it's not the antichrist i think
it'll be like desantis you know what i
mean everything will get really bad and
then desantis will just come in and
[ __ ] be like i could clean this whole
[ __ ] up i'd let him i would accept the
antichrist if he keeps florida florida i
don't give a [ __ ] he leave florida alone
bro he makes everyone get the mark of
the beast except people from florida
because he's like you guys were my
homies yeah yeah you guys are cool you
guys are cool you guys are cool
uh that's what i moved here for us just
so i could uh have the protection of
daddy desantis
dude i mean you think he's gonna run for
president we always what do you think
i i think he will but uh my expectation
is he's probably not running in 24 i
think 28 is i think 20 because he's
young he's young and yeah and honestly
right now like he's done he's the
governor of florida has done more to
affect national politics
than the president than trump did in
four years like honestly if you think
about it like remember he's the one that
ended the mass man they travel mandate
and he goes okay you know what i got rid
of it you go ahead and tell me i've put
their mask back on i [ __ ] dare you
you know
i think between between him and the
canadian trucker uh protest i think
those were like the two things that were
the turning point and you said he's done
more for you know freedom or impacting
the culture in america than biden he's
done more for the globe i honestly think
that if it weren't for florida's example
there's a decent chance that that much
of the world is still locked down it was
a really big turning point because it
got to demonstrate like scientifically
that these lockdowns and mandates and
everything else were not [ __ ] working
had we not had a a you know case study
where we could actually prove that this
is all insanity and that we shouldn't be
going down this path i'm not sure that
they would have stopped how awesome by
the way how awesome is it that us
floridians we're like yeah we'll happily
be the guinea pigs just let us do
whatever the [ __ ] we were like we
volunteered we volunteered
that's fine we'll get covered leave me
alone though i was i was running around
in san diego [ __ ] licking door
handles making out with homeless dudes
like i was trying to get covered i
couldn't get it like for the for the
life of me i can't get this [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] immune i swear some people
aren't gonna get you you know what you
might have even had it and not knowing
you might wanna asymptomatic because i
know a lot of people that ended up
getting it and they were fine you know
yeah i i i also gotta say i enjoy
desantis for how he's literally just
standing off to all these companies and
try to bully politicians all the time
like when he did the mass mandate thing
and he's like we're not gonna make
vaccine mandates here and then carnival
cruise and royal caribbean we're like
we're leaving florida and he's like i
[ __ ] dare you
and then they were like yeah we looked
into the cost analysis there's no way
we're leaving florida yeah i knew you
were never leaving florida stupid and
then disney started their [ __ ] and he's
like you know what maybe you don't get
to have your own imperial district here
in florida anymore like you know i mean
have you seen they've kept their mouth
shut about abortion now disney hasn't
said a goddamn word they're like i don't
care look you listen leave me alone bro
we have our own [ __ ] problems right
now at some point the ceo of publix is
going to get pissed at desantis and he's
going to be like you know what i think
and his wife's going to grab his hand
and go baby shut up just shut up just
shut the [ __ ] up i actually love it and
this has been a major point of
contention amongst the libertarian
community because normally we defend
business against government but in this
situation because these businesses are
uh so deeply in bed with government i'm
like i don't give a [ __ ] like desantis
can tell them whatever the hell he wants
as far as i'm concerned because they're
doing the bidding of the federal
government and and that's not
libertarian either so yeah and well the
disney thing too it was literally
disney was being allowed to be a massive
corporation pay no taxes and to also be
their own government right and it was
like okay you can't have both you got to
pick you got all of this you got to have
all of this and talk my kids into you
know chopping genitals off like that
there's there's got to be a line here
somewhere but that's the thing though
that that's that's the exact point nice
like now
that whole like you know
is like oh you know when they take down
google's a private company are they
though because they get non-compete
government contracts they get tax breaks
they work with senators they're like
everything is so mushed together now
right where you're like where does the
government and where does google begin
honestly like that to me or amazon's
another great example it's like the guy
owns the washington [ __ ] post you
know yeah
yeah well and and same with twitter uh
same with facebook that like all these
companies have contracts with the the
nsa to spy on us oh yeah like if you
think they're not getting compensated
for that and then on top of that they
get dragged uh you know on up on capitol
hill before the politicians where they
they instruct them
on their censorship policies i'm sorry
but that's a violation of the first
amendment right there you cannot
instruct private business to censor me
and then expect me to buy the fact that
that's a private business making that
decision no that's not how it works you
have violated the first amendment just
by coercing these businesses into doing
that so i don't i don't run any cover
for these businesses anymore zero look
at what the eu's doing where you saw we
talked about on the show the eu's trying
to pass these laws that if twitter wants
to be allowed there they have to abide
by their their hate speech laws so it's
a workaround where it's like either okay
twitter can't be in europe
or they have to put these hate speech
laws into place well and then there's
that and there's also when they say well
it's a private company bro and you're
like yeah but we
we now live in this weird
like
dystopian future hellscape where like
seven companies are umbrella companies
that own everything yeah so there is no
competition it's not like there's it's
not like all this private business is
like you know doing whatever they want
it's if you like for instance you make
an app like twitter and you're like all
right we're gonna have twitter but i'm
gonna allow free speech whatever and
immediately you're taking off [ __ ]
the google play store apple store apple
store like so there's too much of that
like
everyone's gotten way too big
every government's gotten way too big
every corporation's gotten too big
and
those businesses have only gotten as big
as they have because of the government
because of their relationship to the
government your your point is exactly
correct though that um you know you said
those seven companies i i talk about
three in particular which is blackrock
state street in vanguard blackrock
yeah those three etfs i mean black black
rock alone owns over five percent of
1400 different major uh corporations in
this in the in the world i mean that is
insane you never had any sort of uh you
know businesses historically that had
that kind of financial control and while
they're they're money managers so it's
not all their assets but they still have
voting rights for that capital yeah they
get to dictate what all of those 1400
companies do and more than that they get
to dictate what companies they haven't
invested in yet will do because they
want that funding of that 10 trillion
plus dollars from blackrock so they are
they have so outsized power uh that they
have to be stopped somehow i don't i
don't know exactly how well
from the dollar bitcoin whatever goldman
sachs bought an entire neighborhood here
in florida did you see that goldman
sachs bought an entire neighborhood yeah
they're like hey can we just have
southwestern volusia county they're like
sure there you go it's all yours
and and that's the thing and that's you
know it's funny because the whole thing
like oh you know
uh then
with the disney thing it was hilarious
because they were like oh these counties
they're gonna have to pay the debt
disney so disney's still trying to be
the good guy like going look we're
saving you money if so if this deal is
so shitty for you disney why are you
fighting for it so hard right but then
desantis goes none of the state will
just take over really creek don't worry
i won't be discharged to the counties
and also the firefighters said they're
gonna they were gonna be fired we're
gonna be giving them a raise and then
they're like [ __ ] now what you know
desantis is good man like what whatever
disagreements i have with them and i do
have a few israel is really good yeah
israel is the main one uh just his
defense of it and it's like look they
can defend themselves they're they've
i don't believe in exporting uh you know
aid to anybody we're we're falling apart
as a nation right now it's insane why
africa exports h to us all the time what
are you talking about it's [ __ ]
terrible monkey box hello
um
no but we also get really hardcore drugs
which people overdose on uh from china
so yeah we get a few exports that's true
yeah yeah you gotta when you're in
florida though you're not gonna be
governor unless you cozy up with some
you cheese what i mean it's so it is
what it is but i i do enjoy i enjoy the
fact
that
you know i think that trump sometimes
didn't you know i know the whole the
whole meme was 4d chess right but i
don't really think he always thought
three steps ahead desantis does seem to
think like steps ahead so it's like i'm
gonna do this
knowing that their reaction is gonna be
this
and then it's like more of a chess game
and then it's like when they do this
then i'm moving this piece but they
don't realize i've already figured out
when i do that i already know what
they're going to do then and that's how
he's just made disney and all these
people spiral it's just like i knew you
were going to go for that and guess what
now you're trying to do 40 tests
desantis is 5d for sure like this this
guy is i honestly i think he is what the
maga movement thought trump was which
trump wasn't uh which is a really shrewd
guy like he he honestly is thinking
ahead he is game planning every uh you
know cultural battleground
before he even steps into it you know he
he absolutely thinks these things out
when he stripped disney i mean disney's
a huge company in in florida like that
could have backfired tremendously oh
yeah
and it didn't so he's he's very smart in
how he's handling it yeah
it's the one he was just like then
[ __ ] leave and i do like that he's
giving trump the old heisman trophy
stiff arm yeah it's true you notice he's
trying to keep that dirt off even when
they're at the same events and stuff
it's like there's no photo ops with
trump there's none of that like he's
just like nah man they're kind of doing
my own thing man that's cool good to see
you though good to see you man i hope
your wife's good how's baron good great
okay see you later bro i got a socially
distance because of the covet
he's just dipping out like here's i
don't i'm not getting all your stink on
me bro i'm not doing it speaking of heel
turns what do you think about ted cruz
what a heel turn on that guy huh
is it a heel turn i mean i mean he was
always that way you're right yeah yeah
in my experience ted has been a [ __ ]
[ __ ] lib his entire life and no no
disrespect to the the great state of
texas but i don't know why they've had
this guy you mean the purple state of
the purple state of texas well you don't
like that well yeah you don't like being
called a terrorist
oh that's right
the january six people terrorists that
was one of those by literal republicans
now being like these terrorists and
you're like he's like oh i'm like
do you know how many people probably
voted for you that were in that crowd
what are you talking about man yeah it's
it's crazy and and ted's been he's been
a warmonger as as long as he's been in
power so like that didn't surprise me
that he's he's on board with uh shipping
billions to ukraine i mean these guys
these guys are really trying to start
world war three like i i know we talk
about it we could joke about it and we
will i'm sure but they're trying to
start world war three lindsey graham
literally went on tv and begged russians
to kill putin
i remember watching that live
and i sat with my jaw the whole chat
just kept saying dead air dead air dead
air because we watched it live and i sat
there with my jaw open like
like frozen it was just like oh my god
lindsey graham
he is
so deeply in the closet he is projecting
all of his angst about his homosexuality
onto the world and we may all die
because of it i don't know if people
understand how dangerous it is for
people to be in the closet their entire
life honestly i do think i think it
should just be like dude we don't care
if you suck dick can we stop killing 18
year old soldiers please thank you yeah
that'd be awesome
as soon as john mccain passed and he no
longer had his butt buddy he was like i
am going to kill the world if it's the
last thing i do i swear that's like
lindsey graham's modus operandi
he leaned into the [ __ ] casket and
kissed him on the forehead and he was
like don't worry johnny baby
i'm gonna finish what you started
you're right
you're right
somber music playing in the beginning we
went in after the funeral was over and
was like just give me give me a minute
with him he's like
don't worry buddy
we're going to finish this thing for you
i got this new boy i got this new
handsome young boy with an eye patch
and he's gonna help me
bro i can imagine john mccain's just
talking up to him from hell going
there's nothing but there's nothing but
uh muslims down here i don't you gotta
stop sending him
let me tell you something by the way can
i say the one who's going to be the this
is let me tell you about the antichrist
okay this guy right here
he is dan crenshaw
is
[ __ ] pure think about it as the
antichrist right he's got an eye patch
so it's like if he becomes it then it's
like how did we not we should know right
right the guy had an eye patch we should
have known something's always off
it's like seeing klaus schwab and not
just automatically assuming that he's a
you know evil villain oh or sorrow soros
is another one where you're like that's
a bad guy right
i mean he looks like a bad guy
[ __ ] it i don't know how they see klaus
in his [ __ ] his like sith lord outfit
and they don't just automatically assume
like yeah this guy when he talks about
saving the world he doesn't mean it yeah
klaus schwab has a [ __ ] uh uh
a face that looks like an antique plague
mask
like the turn of the century
it's [ __ ] bad dude i'm telling you
man crenshaw is you saw you so i'm sure
you saw the video when he yelled at that
kid right
when crenshaw yelled at the 12 year old
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
dude
you're like don't challenge my my crisp
my religion my faith or whatever it was
like oh my god bowed up on like a 12
year old girl and i'm like wow that's a
tough dude there huh it was at his rally
yeah it's a fundraiser for him
she's just lucky that he didn't have a
drone in the air he would have [ __ ]
taken her out
oh man that and then [ __ ] hannity
basically going like kathy was a january
six so there's no way that she should
like what the [ __ ] happening bro neal
hannity's pushing for more three-letter
agencies to be formed just so he can get
more pins on his lapel right
he's like i'm not working for enough
three-letter agencies i want my i want
this whole thing filled up like i'm a
[ __ ] north korean general
you need to form more agencies oh let me
okay now i want to find out how
libertarian clint is i like playing this
game because there's
just libertarian people think oh you're
a libertarian you're one thing there's a
lot of different type of libertarians
i've learned left-leaning
left-leaning ones are the worst but yes
anyway let me ask you immigration
you're for it you get it
uh
well i don't hate immigration
just across the board i think right but
there are many great immigrants to this
country but i am also not an open
borders libertarian where there it is
you just let everyone come in and you
just deal with whatever problems come
from that i think that's also insane uh
and for the longest time that has been
the libertarian party's position that
they were open borders and i i could not
disagree more i think that you have to
you have to end the war on terror the
war on drugs all these other status
problems uh that have created
you know millions of refugees that would
flood here excuse me the war on drugs is
going great okay nobody's dying from
drugs anymore all right nancy reagan won
bro
fentanyl is not the number two killer of
adults 18 to 40. it's [ __ ] everything
has fentanyl in it halloween candy may
have fentanyl xanax has fentanyl in it
and i'm like oh my dunkin donuts coffee
had fentanyl in it the other day no i
just fell asleep in my car for like a
half hour it's true he was doing the
show he was h nodding in and out they
had to come give me one of those narcan
pens so i could come do the show
as
unsuccessful as the war on drugs has
been i think the war on terror is
equally unsuccessful you have you have
uh you know yemen somalia uh
syria all these other countries that you
know looked like they were okay and now
we're just we're at war with them too uh
not to mention europe which is being
overran by uh immigration from refugees
from uh these war-torn countries which
we continuously bomb it's just i mean
ron paul was right i mean that's that's
just a fact ron paul's been right about
a lot of stuff and what bothers me is
that we always joke about it but like
whenever lefties get whenever you try to
fight them about censorship they all
turn into ron paul just for that issue
like it's a private company like you
used to yell at me when i said that you
used to say you used to yell at me you
[ __ ] commie you don't get to tell me
that now man don't let them use our
defense don't they don't believe it they
don't mean it just just keep it moving
they don't mean any of that [ __ ]
remember when he was polling like second
and third and like
they would just give them they just
wouldn't say his name like it would be
up on the chart on tv and he would they
would just not say his name and you're
like even even johnson
was the one that was like behind him
[Laughter]
dude it's it's it's it's [ __ ] it's
bad i know you're you're you're at that
big libertarian convention coming up
here right
like you're a big shot in that community
yeah yeah i'm gonna be in reno uh
thursday through monday before we get to
reno no we know don't rub your money in
our face
wow
okay millionaire i don't know you're
going to reno
hey i didn't i didn't [ __ ] decide
where they're putting it
i don't know why i don't know why it's
in reno either it makes it for uh dual
stuff oh the biggest little city in the
world why
no idea what's more libertarian than
reno though vegas is only a couple of
hours from there it's probably more
expensive to fly into reno
i don't even understand this oh it's
definitely more expensive for us to fly
in but i would imagine that there's like
three casinos there's more casinos in
biloxi okay look the hey next year this
is next year convention biloxi
mississippi let's go we'll go to that
i'll go to biloxi
all right i'm down let's i would rather
have it like
move it to mardi gras let's party this
[ __ ] uh yeah so there's gonna be
a thousand delegates i'll be one of them
i get to vote on the entire platform and
who's going to be the national
representatives for the libertarian
party so uh the mises caucus is is like
dave smith's and a bunch of other
people's brain child where we're
essentially the the ron paul revolution
is back and we're taking over the
libertarian party so that's that's
what's happening um i i hope that we'll
be successful it looks like we will but
the the votes don't come down until this
weekend
it is funny watching libertarian like
the libertarian party
have been trying to for like a couple
years now they've been trying to
immunize themselves against all these
mises guys
and like it's funny how these guys
stopped acting like libertarians and
started being all like political
operatives and [ __ ] and it was like
really funny to see it uh that's
fascinating that you that you actually
even caught wind of that how did you
hear about that oh i mean i've been
following the liberty i've i've leaned
libertarian i'm not a libertarian i'm a
republican but i mean i lean more you
know on the liberty side of most issues
and i follow dave smith and i follow uh
you know i've been following his
constant fighting with people on twitter
with with people in the party and it's
it's kind of fun to watch because he
says [ __ ] that makes sense and then they
just [ __ ] spurge out on him he is
very reasonable too his argument's
always really reasonable he's not
aggressive or anything and like you
piece of [ __ ] you fascist i'm like what
the [ __ ] yeah it's been fun to watch and
then you have libertarians bringing up
like legion of skanks and stuff oh
that's hilarious oh yeah because you
just saw some racist podcast
we're doing that now the liberty we're
doing that now we're doing the racist
thing now
well this is why the purge was necessary
is because you had people that that
don't believe in freedom of speech or
freedom of association or any of that
they don't believe in those things which
are you know core uh libertarian
principles and and also conservative
ones and many of them were formerly
democrat or liberal ones too but they've
completely done away with that but
you're right they they showed their true
colors they really took the mask off and
they were they were booting you know
entire
groups of mises caucus people from state
affiliation they were doing all sorts of
like crazy which that helps that's how
that helps third party get votes guys
that's not very i don't know libertarian
of them
i mean
that's like literally the opposite of
what libertarian means that's a great
idea though hey we're having a we have a
third party that's struggling to gain a
foothold in this country we should kick
out everyone that doesn't agree with me
by the way
one of the people who by the way is a
huge comic that everybody knows now is
hilarious to me it's like yeah we don't
want that national exposure where's gary
johnson is he yeah
yeah we not necessarily
not gary johnson who was the old talk
show guy daryl something uh uh the guy
he's from the old libertarian department
oh oh but he's like what's next a
license to own a damn toaster oven that
weird
that guy was my favorite yeah like like
all these cartoon character guys that
they run and you're like i mean can you
can you get can you let the young like
jewish fought married father who
actually could speak well
can you give him a shot i mean he's kind
of funny and he might win people over
that's the greatest part about it is he
he is
just overwhelmingly uh persuasive he's
probably the best messenger for
libertarianism in my lifetime no
disrespect to ron paul uh dave has the
capacity to reach
reach anybody he's been on joe rogan
seven times that's spoken to tens of
millions of people he's opened more eyes
about the atrocities of the war in yemen
than any human being on earth i mean you
can't you cannot
like i don't know how they can fail to
appreciate what he's accomplished for
the libertarian cause and yet they they
would
gleefully see him you know
excommunicated it's just insane so
that's what we're going to do because
like every movement like minute look at
the look at tea party is a great example
of something started with good
intentions and then it turns into this
weird money making boomer fest then
you're selling tea party pillows you
know
and and that's that's just what happened
occupy wall street is another one good
intentions and then it turns into like
yeah man drum circle let's let's do
ayahuasca here in front of wall street
and i'm like okay i get it that sounds
fun but
how is that going to stop the banks you
know what i mean like
um but it is good to just see
libertarians get away from like the porn
stars and the guy with a boot on his
head and the [ __ ] you know what i
mean people showing up in darth vader
costumes and just all the weird cartoon
characters that would always pop up it's
like oh thank god just get these guys
while they're the libertarians that have
like rent is too damn high guys i had
80s 80s wrestling gimmicks is what the
material party was turning into
it was and you know i get it when you're
a third party you're going to do
outlandish [ __ ] to try and get attention
but when when the world is falling apart
you don't need to put a boot on your
head to get people to pay attention to
you you just have to tell the truth by
the way that's a really good point we
can't feed babies i mean the boot on the
head's hilarious but there's no food for
babies we have a baby formula yeah
or you get the libertarian there's a
reason we don't have baby formula it's
because you didn't listen to the
libertarians because you locked down the
[ __ ] economy and that was a
catastrophic mistake that anybody that
has any semblance of economic
understanding knew right away was going
to result in inflation and [ __ ]
supply chain shortages and everything
else that we're experiencing today and
the libertarians were the only ones that
were actually speaking out against it
for the most part i mean there was
obviously some republicans that did too
but the libertarians like that's our
bread and butter man like we know you
cannot [ __ ] with the economy and expect
not to pay a price and they didn't
listen to us and now we're paying the
price so now we get to go up on and say
hey we were warning you two years ago
maybe you should consider our ideas a
little bit more deeply um and i hope i
hope that we can do that in the near
future yeah but here's the problem
how much money do you give the google
see that's how you decide that's who
decides the real elections how much
money do you give the facebook you're
right but but i think i think that this
is this is the good thing about the the
continued suppression of of speech
across all these platforms youtube
twitter facebook everywhere else is that
it's forcing um people to seek out you
know fringe shows like yours and mine
and and dave's and all these other and
and now rogan is the biggest platform
you can possibly be on and he's
essentially independent like they've
they've already they've already tried to
cancel the guy and spotify told him to
kick rocks this dude has too many
eyeballs on him they came off 200
million dollars they're not gonna find
they're gonna dump a 200 million dollar
guaranteed contract because two blue
haired trans people at spotify got mad
sorry to be fair though they have taken
down episodes well with joe joe did that
joe did though to be fair to to just to
be fair that was his his compromise
there were certain episodes that he took
like the owen benjamin episodes are not
on spotify for example one i could think
off the top of my head of somebody
that's not on there who are the other
one though the black not the black rifle
coffee guy the other guy the on it guy
that was talking about
like medical misinformation that episode
was taken off so there's a few
that he has taken off uh himself but i
think that joe rogan thing is like trust
me look there's a lot of reasons to make
fun of joe rogan okay but
that being said it is funny seeing them
coming after a guy who's really a middle
of the road dude like joe rogan's a
middle of the road guy right for the
most part he had bernie sanders on his
show you know what i mean
he endorsed bernie basically i mean he
loves the guy so yeah he's he's
really the every man as weird as that
sounds uh because he's such a wealthy
human being
i'm sorry yeah most most every man have
three salt tanks in their mansion you're
right
but i'm saying i'm saying ideologically
like he leans left he leans right he's
he's got you know differences of opinion
and and what what i think makes him
really valuable is that because he is so
uh you know financially well-off now and
because he does
think freely um that platform is
invaluable i mean it's it's the biggest
platform maybe ever okay so here's a
question you just reminded me so you you
tweeted out last week you tweeted out
brandon chob is the funniest comedian of
our lifetime out of the way george
carlin what did you mean by that
[ __ ] say that
why would you say something so brave you
had so controversial yeah why was this
so brave and said so controversial dude
i just watched the george garland
documentary last night and i and i
realized that i used carlin's
argumentation against war constantly and
i did and i like it's all just uh you
know through the ether from like
watching him as a child and i put these
arguments into my brain and now i use
them without even like citing the guys
you know what's funny the guy the guy
that run do you know the guy that runs
carlin's estate is a fan of our show for
real and he sent us like a bunch of
george carlin shirts and [ __ ] that was
awesome yeah he's like yeah he would
have really liked you guys i'm like
probably not but okay man
i don't think carla well i don't think
cardinal like anybody glad glad you
liked us that was cool but that was
awesome
getting to watch him um watch that
documentary it's on hbo plus if anybody
wants to check it out it is phenomenal
like that you get to watch his entire
his entire career arc his entire life
arc and uh man what a genius what a what
a profound thinker even though i
strongly disagree with him on many many
things just just absolutely brilliant i
i i can't speak highly enough about it i
know you're more you're more of a hannah
gatsby guy you're more of a neck guy but
that's pretty cool for you
i'm just going to make up this room
while you leave and go hey man i heard
clip from luffy lockdown like really
likes the net i don't know why he's into
that it's [ __ ] weird
i was a big fighter in the kid fan back
in the day i'm so sorry
look we've always said this and we've
said this many times
brian callan is very funny okay he is i
think he's funny okay brian kellen's
funny mercies but brian counts flight we
agree on that brendan shaw's stupidest
person that's ever lived on this planet
and i look i'm not saying it's not even
his fault i think he has ct i think he's
in combat he got punched into stupidity
but then when he started like suing
people i'm like all right man they're
just making fun of you you're special
sucks bro i don't know what to tell you
man oh man when when i heard that he was
suing people for you know like small
youtube channels yeah i was like oh
brother that that you are losing all all
respect from me right now that's just
absolutely horrific and they won't even
say it like all they're saying is your
comedy sucks which it does like he's
he's a funny guy on podcast in my
opinion uh but his stand-up is [ __ ]
really not very good gringo just really
not gringo poppy was you you wasn't
picking
[Applause]
he didn't like when he was naming all
the foods yeah i was it wasn't a big it
wasn't a big fan of that um
i mean it's like it's like c minus t
like it's like barely above
open micro so and i'm a huge fan of
comedy so like i could still see it and
go like all right yeah you were a
heavyweight fighter you were a contender
in the ufc you've only been doing comedy
three or four years just stop doing
specials like you could i think he could
actually get to a point of being funny
maybe but like he's just not there yet
no he's brain dead dude we watched a
clip of him when he first came into
ultimate fighter when he was a young
dude he talks like a different person
totally a different person like he got
punched into retardation like the
muhammad ali thing or the boxer from uh
[ __ ] death the smoochie yeah brendan
jobs basically uh uh [ __ ] what's his
name spinner done yeah spinnerbait
that's him every time he sees rogan at
the comedy store
honestly i think i think his entire
career like he's like hey what's going
on brandon no uh brenton
[Laughter]
his entire career is based on the fact
that rogan feels bad for him because he
saw his brain get destroyed live in
front of him for his entertainment and
now he's trying to help the guy maybe
it's just like four years ago he's like
i don't know man i lost a couple fights
and rogan's like man you just got train
hard and stick with it and then he got
totally [ __ ] after that rogan just
felt responsible
ever since
[Laughter]
running around like oh god
they're like we just keep them around
the sword at this point as like a mascot
[Laughter]
running around in capri pants
with his sneakers on his table whatever
man hate him
anyway
he tried to [ __ ] bobby lee's [ __ ] dude i
know that was one of the best things
when he was like when he was like he
asked for like a [ __ ] or whatever and
then they outed him on on their trash
tuesday show which sucks because it's
women talking so it's terrible and um
then the whole thing started where he
got an investigative team that thought
bobby lee was behind a threat to his
family's life on reddit and when they
asked him for the when they
for proof it was just a bunch of html
code
with somebody named
robert lee
dude i swear man
there's these some of these guys always
do that they'll be like people threaten
me or people write these things and it's
like
okay well then you shouldn't be doing
internet content because if you have
more than 100 followers eventually
you're going to start getting i'm going
to [ __ ] kill you you know what i mean
like it's just it's inevitable i get
threats i get threats like of course he
gets threats what are we even talking
about like i don't even understand and
and he's also like one of the most
dangerous human beings on earth like no
one could actually mess with him in in
combat so
and he's got money just by security i
don't understand well because because i
think he wants to be something he wants
to be known as something other than the
fighter right other than a ufc guy he
wants to you know break that mold and he
thinks that he's probably been told by
his other friends in the locker room
that hey you're a funny guy you should
do stand-up you know we we lie to people
and
and then we do and and then he goes and
i think the reason people are mad is not
that he's not funny because he's not
funny and that's fine you don't you
don't have some people aren't right but
it's the fact that there's comedians
that we know are way funnier that work
that that are working hard and they
didn't get a showtime special because
they're joe rogan's friend i think that
that is why people are mad i think
people are like all right man but like
you leapfrogged everybody and now you go
you know you take with your porsche you
go park up front and you take the front
spot at the comedy club people got mad
and i think all that would have been
forgiven if he went on showtime and just
[ __ ] nailed it if he killed him if
you would have killed him
all right all's forgiven you maybe you
did leap frog people but [ __ ] them but
the fact that he leapfrogged everyone
just to get on show time just to pull
his pants down and piss and [ __ ] on the
stage
you know what i mean it's like
why this is this is why other people
didn't get their thing yeah
like they were they were planning the uh
the event and and brennan goes to the
producer he's like hey make sure that
you put a bed up there on this and the
producer's like on the stage and he's
like yeah put it up there i'm gonna [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
that seems like that was his actual plan
was to just go up there and do the worst
stand-up humanly possible i don't know i
don't know how he he's he's friends with
you know really funny people like theo
vaughn and all these other guys that are
just incredibly hilarious and yet
that none of them came to him and said
brother you ain't you ain't ready you
ain't ready for a special right now no
because i don't understand how that's
possible la is all about
la and new york are very different
beasts and in new york they all trash
each other they're really they're all
friendly but they're all mean to each
other in la they're all fake nice to
each other none of them trash each other
it's all very much an la vibe and so
yeah i'm sure nobody went up to him and
said this isn't good in new york he
would have gotten better because people
would have been like that's your [ __ ]
did a whole bit about [ __ ] mexican
food just saying it funny you should
[ __ ] quit stupid hang yourself when
you get home tonight well it made people
better you know
maybe he thinks that comedy's an std
that's why he's trying to [ __ ] all these
comics wives did you think about that
think about that maybe he's smarter than
all trying to catch bobby lee's funny
yeah but he's smarter than all of us
watch out will sasso's wife
who else was on mad tv that he's coming
after yeah i mean if i could say helen's
sister if i could sexually contract
someone's funny level i would definitely
go after whoever will sasso's there
that's true only funny that's hilarious
he's the funniest person ever and it's a
crime that he's not like the biggest
[ __ ] name brandon schaub is stalking
phil lamar's ex-girlfriend's house
phil lamar that's right he was on mad tv
i know all the deep cuts bro that was
that's a good reference deep cut lamar
is a good reference yeah lamar man he
does a bunch of voices now i think fox's
tim meadows yes yes oh man tim meadows
was on snl for like 500 years pete
davidson's left he's leaving snl did you
see that
and kate mckinnon they're gone this is
their last season
oh you know what god god forbid
everybody's celebrating the fact that
he's not on snl anymore and i'm going to
tell you all right now hold your [ __ ]
horses
because i have a feeling this means
we're going to be seeing more of pete
davis yeah
we're going to get a lot of pete
davidson movies
we're going to get a lot of pete
davidson tv shows and we're going to get
probably some sort of hbo max spin-off
pete davidson sketch show or something
cause that's what keeps them tight like
they're not allowed to do a lot of other
stuff yeah and now it's just going to be
non-stop
pete [ __ ] davidson yep i don't know i
don't know if funny is necessarily
contagious but i think you can actually
lose funny by [ __ ] too many hot
broads because pete has like he's gone
downhill he's gonna suffer since he got
every starlet on the planet and now he's
just funny whatever my opinion you
thought he was funny i never thought i
thought he was all right i don't know i
just i don't i think he's the worst
thing to have come from 911.
that is true that is true
that that's including the tsa oh really
wow that's a [ __ ] hyper if i if i
could trade him for his father i would
i'll say that [ __ ] trust me i think
his dad would say that too if he was
around probably
probably would be better on snow have
you seen king of staten island a no
amount of bill bird's gonna fix that
movie pete sorry buddy
no amount of bill bert's gonna fix it
yeah sorry not even dave cyrus can write
you out of this one
i think i think that's probably the the
woke
yeah the aspect of wokeness taking over
comedy that's offended me most is that
people like will sasso and bill burr and
all these other geniuses aren't like the
biggest thing out there because they're
so [ __ ] funny
billboard you know booper's funny
billboard billboard's getting a lot of
tv now though he's been in a he's been
in like movies he was in star wars now
he married a black woman so he was he
was he was excited
it's so funny you said that that's
exactly what we say too it's like yeah
yeah we know we know why you're still
getting invited to parties bill we've
heard some of the old stuff and let's
put it this way you didn't used to say
mary you used to say a different word
that you call people and it wasn't mary
buddy was it
uh
um but anyway it was [ __ ] but anyway um
i said i just want to make sure some
people don't even know maybe brandon
schwab's listening
uh dude two hours that was a lot of fun
man thanks for being on
this was i've been on for two hours now
you've been off for an hour but two
hours of our show you were in the second
hour oh yeah
well thank you for for having me guys uh
you do a great show so can we get uh
can we get all the uh you know how do we
get them and yeah that's what else about
this right now where can they find you
i'm on youtube so search liberty
lockdown you'll find me uh app on
twitter youtube what's that is it an app
youtube i've never heard of it is it how
do i get can i get youtube on my phone
can you get youtube on your phone it's a
nokia how does it i think
it's it's this new upstart um i think
they they plan to not do anything evil
so okay cool it should be as long as
they promise it and never take that out
of their name i'll agree with you
sorry
liberty lockdown on youtube where else
can they find you
at libertylog pod on twitter and then
just search liberty lockdown elsewhere
uh clint russell doesn't come up on most
search [ __ ] because i was in the closet
about my full name back in the day so uh
just search liberty lockdown you'll find
me but thank you guys for uh for having
me this is so this is a lot of fun man
thanks for coming on man
you're welcome on anytime
okay and vice versa yeah i mean not like
every day every day would be where
you're here now just be the co-host but
yeah i mean anytime like do me a friend
out like everyone else call dave and
tell me you're not tell dave you can't
make it to reno you got a new gig yeah
this is a verbal contract i'm in here
tell them we're headed to biloxi yep
we're go to biloxi with the boys sorry
can't make it your little conference
all right bud take it easy dude
see ya
all right and there he goes man that was
that was great